well everyone it seems like we made it
to episode three um somehow i'm still
absolutely trucking through these even
though it's snowing by me in march which
blows and in addition to that my wrist
is killing me both from lifting weights
and another reason that i will not
disclose
for today's video we'll actually be
getting into multi-leader replication
which is where even i start not being
able to understand what the hell is
happening
so with that being said let's get into
this powerpoint and hopefully we can
work things out together can't wait
until someone corrects me in the
comments and uh
they'll probably be right here we go
okay so let's talk about multi-leader
replication
just as a throwback to the last slide
the types of replication are single
leader multi-leader in leaderless and
i'll be talking about the second one
today
in terms of the overview for
multi-leader replication as opposed to
just having one leader right now that
all the rights can go to there are many
of them and possibly even across data
centers
so leader databases will actually send
each other rights however the reads can
come from any database
so i mentioned there that there are
multiple multi-leader replication
topologies on that slide and now here
are three that we'll talk about
there are others besides this things
like chain replication but for our sake
right now let's just talk about these
three
so the issue with circular and star
topology is that they are less fall
resistant
as you can see if one node on the ring
in the circular topology fails those
rights are going to stop being passed
along and if the middle node in the star
topology fails those rights are going to
stop being passed along
unlike those the all to all topology
where all writes are sent from all
leader nodes to all the other leader
nodes doesn't have that fault tolerance
problem however it does have the problem
that rights can easily be sent out of
order
this is a result of a network race
condition where say
you know two leaders are sending
causally related rights to a third
leader and they get there in the wrong
order which then violates our consistent
prefix reads that we talked about
in the last video
that can kind of be solved with a
technique that we'll discuss later in
the video called version vectors but for
now just note that it's pretty hard to
reason about um you know writes coming
in out of order in that all to all
topology
okay what are the trade-offs of
multi-leader replication because
obviously compared to single leader
replication there are some clear
differences
the first is that right throughput
actually gets distributed more so
amongst multiple leaders which
potentially means that for right heavy
workloads multiple leader replication
might be more suitable it's also good
because it means we can put a leader in
multiple data centers which allows our
app to be more globalized the biggest
the biggest downside of all this is that
you actually have to deal with right
conflicts between multiple leaders
okay so let's discuss some forms of
conflict resolution that multi-leader
replication style databases use
the first one that we'll actually talk
about is conflict avoidance which isn't
really resolution but it's actually just
avoiding them how could we do that we
would actually just have all rights for
the same item going to a given leader we
can do this via some hashing function
and i guess effectively if you really
think about it it's kind of just like
partitioning but then putting partitions
in geographically different areas
this isn't always possible if a the
leader is down or b you want to change
the configuration of your database setup
and as a result now we have
writes going to a different leader for a
little bit and then you may have
conflicts
okay the next one which is pretty simple
to talk about is last right wins each
right is assigned some sort of time
stamp so that can either be like an
actual clock time stamp or it can be
something like a lan port timestamp
which i'll discuss in a future video
the pro of this is that it's very easy
to implement it's definitely being used
in some distributed key value stores
like cassandra
the biggest con of this is that there
are a lot of questions about it so do we
use the client or the server time stamp
if i have an offline change on one of my
computers like i don't know a google doc
and then i eventually connect online and
push that right which time stamp am i
using the one from when i physically
wrote the document or from when it
connects to the server
additionally rights are just going to be
lost if i write something and then my
friend writes something a second later
the thing that i wrote is just
completely gone from history and there's
just no way for me to even know that
anyone overwrote my data
and then finally there is something
called clock skew which is a problem in
distributed computing where not all
servers actually have the same time on
them because
inherently the thing that keeps time on
a computer can actually go a little bit
out of sync so sometimes servers can
actually be up to a few seconds off if
they're not synchronized with some time
server frequently enough which means
that these timestamps as much as we want
to think they're super accurate and can
actually predict which rights should be
winning are not necessarily accurate
okay the next type of conflict
resolution is on read it means that if
we determine that there are some
concurrent rights we store both
concurrent rights in the database and
then those are returned to a user on a
read and the user has to actually merge
them and make it so there's only one
value for those two rights
so say you have two lists like shopping
carts you might merge them together
furthermore there's also on right
conflict resolution which is the
database detects two concurrent rights
and uses some sort of pre-existing code
or some sort of function to actually
merge those rights together it's
important in these cases that that
function for merging is both commutative
and associative so that it doesn't
matter what order those rights are
merged in because obviously the the
rights might reach different leader
nodes in different orders and you want
to be able to you know keep track of all
the history of the rights and not
actually losing any of them which is why
it's important that it's associative
this is kind of the idea between
something called crdts conflict-free
replicated data types which are data
types like counters or incrementers and
decrementers
sets ordered lists that basically
keep track of
certain data structures and every single
time that those end up
you know being synced across those
leaders they're merged properly
okay so now we actually want to be able
to detect concurrent rights because i've
mentioned this a lot
the entire premise behind you know what
actually is a concurrent right is kind
of the knowledge made when making a
write so if i make a write without
knowing about my friends right before
making mine they're concurrent
same goes for him if he makes a right
without first knowing what i wrote to
the database it's concurrent if he makes
a right and then i somehow read it and
then make a write myself they're not
concurrent because his right clearly
happened before mine i actually knew
about it so in this sense concurrency
doesn't actually have anything to do
with physical time that a right is made
it's more so about the knowledge and the
dependencies that i had when making my
own write
so keeping this in mind it moves us on
to something called version vectors
version vectors are a way to explicitly
keep track of what each client and
database knows about the value of a
given key so basically imagine i have n
replicas a version vector is a list of
length n which basically incorporates
how many times
that key has been updated by each
database and as a result it lets you
track the dependencies of every single
write
and
tell if two writes are concurrent
okay so
trying to express this on just like a
pretty small example let's imagine i
have two clients me and my friend and
two replicas which are each going to be
holding my shopping cart on amazon
so let's assume i'm client one the first
thing i want to do is go ahead and you
know set the jordan's shopping cart key
to add a playstation 5. okay so i am
going to pass version vector 0 0 which
means as far as i'm aware neither
replica has processed or right for the
jordan's shopping cart key
once replica a receives my right it's
going to go ahead and say that it is now
processed one right which makes the
version vector one comma zero and the
value corresponding to one comma zero
being ps5
now let's say my friend sucks so he
wants to add an xbox
so he also does not realize that either
replica has processed or right so he is
now going to write to replica b
and he's going to try and add an xbox so
now replica b is going to update its own
internal version number or version
vector to zero comma one which means as
far as replica b is aware replica a has
processed zero writes for this key and
replica b has now processed one right
for the key let's say now that i want to
add lotion because obviously i want to
keep my skin nice nice and smooth
and you know i can add tissues later
so now as far as replica a is aware it's
process two writes for this key b it
still doesn't realize it's process to
write so replica a's version vector is
going to be two comma zero and the array
of my shopping cart is going to be a
playstation 5 and some lotion
okay
now this is where it gets a little bit
more complicated as we can see those
rights are kind of concurrent because
replica a and or basically me and my
friend don't know that we were each
writing if you look at the version
vectors that we have
they're concurrent because neither is
strictly greater than one another in all
indexes of the array
so let's imagine now that finally
eventual consistency strikes and those
changes are propagated propagated from
replica a to replica b and vice versa
so what's going to happen
they're going to look at the version
vector 2 comma 0 they're going to look
at the version vector 0 comma 1. they're
going to say all right these are clearly
concurrent why is that because replica a
doesn't know that replica b had
processed to write and replica b doesn't
know that replica a had processed a
couple of writes so as a result what
we're going to do is merge them in this
case
if this was an on right conflict
resolution method perhaps we would
actually merge these two lists with some
sort of like array union but let's say
it's on read and our job is to just
store the siblings or the concurrent
rights themselves then all we would do
is have two separate lists corresponding
to a new version vector which is two
comma one how do we get that we go
through both version vectors two comma
zero and zero comma one and for each
index of those version vectors we take
the maximum between the two which means
now as far as we're aware replica a is
process two writes replica b has
processed one right and those
corresponding concurrent values are ps5
and lotion and also xbox we have those
two different cards now let's say either
client one or client 2 wanted to read
the cart
they would potentially get 2 possible
values for the read if client 1 or
client 2 didn't actually make a read and
explicitly just tried to write again
then client 1 would try and make another
addition to say replica a and only
passing the version vector 2 0. so let's
say i passed in 2 0 trying to add
something like tissues then what would
happen is the next step would be that
replica a holds the value 3 comma 1
where it's ps5 lotion tissues and also a
separate shopping cart of xbox
so like i said you know the way that um
these
conflicting values are going to get
rectified depends on whether we're using
an on read or an on right conflict
resolution schema
okay let's talk about version vector
semantics so this is actually a pretty
done slide and truthfully i went through
most of this in the last slide but to
just try and formalize things a little
bit every time a client reads a value
from a database so we're reading a key
the database is going to give it the
version vector that the database holds
for that corresponding key
every time a client writes to the
database it's going to pass in the last
version vector that it got for that key
so that might be from a previous write
or from a previous read upon successful
writes the database will then give it an
updated version vector to use for future
writes
so now we have to say okay well what
makes two version vectors potentially
concurrent or not concurrent well let's
talk about what makes two version
vectors not concurrent which means they
have a causal relationship
two version vectors have a happens
before relationship if one version
vector is strictly greater than or equal
to the other which means that
for every single index in that version
vector each element is going to be
greater or equal to the element from the
other version vector
which means that you know this right has
basically taken in all of the
information from the other right before
actually being written so we know that
the dependencies have been properly
tracked
if there isn't this relationship if say
like you know index 0 of version vector
1 is greater than index 0 of version
vector 2 but index 0 of sorry index one
of version vector one is less than index
one of version vector two
then they're probably going to be
concurrent and there's no way that one
write knew about the other hence we have
to deal with conflict resolution
so that's how you would use version
vectors to determine which rights are
concurrent and then you would have to
use some sort of custom application
specific conflict resolution logic in
order to kind of deal with the fact that
there are concurrent rights this is
obviously not ideal and if you can get
away with avoiding conflicts you should
be doing so
so going back to a conclusion slide and
this is one that we had earlier but just
to reiterate now that you guys
understand a little bit better
the trade-offs of multi-leader
replication are as follows
you have a lot more right throughput by
virtue of potentially being able to put
a leader in every single data center
at the cost of having to deal with
potentially complicated conflict
resolution logic
it happens to be the case that some
applications are really read heavy and
as a result they can get away with
single leader replication however in the
event that you have more of a right uh
right heavy application and you need
that extra throughput then you're
probably gonna have to start dealing
with conflicts
um i hope this helped a lot guys i know
that this is actually like kind of a
pretty complicated topic version vectors
are no joke and since then a lot of
these distributed systems have kind of
you know optimized on those even more i
think there's a dotted version vector
and something called ryak which is
another distributed key value store
some databases like cassandra as i
mentioned earlier have chosen to keep it
simple and just use last right wins
and then others are going to
increasingly rely more on things like
crdts which hopefully take care of a lot
of that logic for you and simplify
things like distributed sets distributed
lists and distributed counters
all right i hope this was helpful i'm
gonna do leaderless or dynamo style
replication next so i hope you guys are
looking forward to that but uh yeah have
a good one